three friends go after a hacker but when
they find him they're attacked by a
strange creature and upon waking realize
that they're in a completely unknown
place
today on cinema recapped i'll show you
the signal
the movie begins with three friends one
who can't walk properly named nick
a girl named haley
and a guy with glasses named jonah we're
going on a trip through the southwestern
united states one night they are
threatened by a hacker and the friends
get mad because apparently it's not the
first time he's messed with them so nick
and jonah start investigating the guy
and managed to discover his location
they plan to go find him the next day
they start their journey and on the way
nick regrets going since he does not
want to expose haley who apparently is
his girlfriend so he tells his friend
jonah to cancel the plan
they go to hailey's house and on the way
they stop to have a coffee
at that moment we see that nick is angry
and sad
because haley will move soon and they
will not be able to see each other much
haley notices the nick is acting strange
so she decides to talk to him
and he tells her that due to an illness
he might not be able to walk again
so he tells her that when she moves
they should break up haley gets angry so
she goes back to the car while nick goes
to see jonah and he convinces him to
continue with the plan to go find the
hacker then the three friends decide to
go together to the place where the
hacker supposedly lives and they realize
that it is a lonely house
nick tells haley to stay locked in the
car while he and jonah are going to see
inside the house
then nick and jonah enter the house
looking for the hacker but they only
find some dusty furniture they decide to
go to the basement
and only find some shelves for servers
at that moment they hear haley screaming
so they run out of the house where they
realize that the car doors are open and
that hayley is gone nick and jonah start
looking for their friend but when they
find her she suddenly flies up into the
air
everything becomes very confusing and
suddenly nick wakes up in a wheelchair
he is transported to a room where a man
enters
wearing a suit that covers his entire
body the man starts to write something
in a notebook and asks nick his name
nick answers and also asks him where he
is to which the man answers that he's in
a safe place
and the man asked him when he found
the sign
for the first time nick doesn't know
what to answer and just asks why he
can't move the man tells him that he and
his friends had contact with an
extraterrestrial biological entity
and are contaminated at that moment nick
has blood coming out of his nose so the
man tells him that they're done for
today and sends nick to his room
guarded by other men in suits
the next day nick is transported again
and on the way he sees hayley in a room
lying on a bed
but they don't let him near her
then nick is taken back to the suited
man and this time dick asks him to let
him talk daily but the man tells him
that it's not possible
and that if he wants the girl to be okay
he must cooperate nick agrees to
cooperate and the man asks him some
questions and then shows him a recording
that nick and jonah made when entering
the hacker's house
a video in which the alien can be seen
then nick is taken to his room
in there he hears jonah's voice coming
from one of the ventilation ducks
so he approaches and starts talking to
him jonah tells him that they're
underground and they must get out of
there as soon as possible another day
nick is taken to the suited man who asks
him if he feels his legs and nick tells
him not yet
then nick asks him to let him see haley
or else he'll not talk anymore
so the man ends up accepting and if he's
taken to see the girl although she is in
a coma nick begins to devise a plan to
escape and tells this plan to his friend
jonah through the pipes
later we see the suited people
experimenting with a creature
when suddenly it escapes them so they
activate an alert
nick who is being transported in the
wheelchair is locked in a room while
they catch the creature
after a few minutes nick comes out and
realizes that the walls are torn
so when they take him to see the suited
man he asks what happened but the man
does not answer him nick asks him if
jonah is okay but the man tells him that
jonah is not inside the facility
nick replies that he talked to donut
through the duct but the man tells him
that's impossible
and it must have just been his
imagination
then nick decides to implement his plan
and man it is to escape from his room
and also takes hayley out on a stretcher
however just when they're at the exit
they get caught
then nick wakes up and sees that
hayley's eyes are open
so they talk for a while and then haley
goes back to sleep at that moment the
men separate them
nick falls out of bed when trying to
defend himself and realizes that his
feet are covered with some kind of alien
technology
he gets scared and starts screaming the
suited man tries to calm him down but
nick asks why they did not tell him
anything about his feet before
and the man replies he did not want to
scare him
then nick gets up and begins to learn
how to use his new feet realizing that
they have much more strength than normal
so decides to knock down the door of the
room and then take haley and get out of
there fast nick uses an elevator to go
up to the surface but the suited man
catches up with him and asks him not to
leave since there's something out there
that will hurt him and only they can
protect him nick doesn't listen to him
and threatens to kick him so the man
moves away
then nick goes up in the elevator and
when he gets out he only sees a solitary
land
at that moment hayley wakes up so she
and nick walks slowly looking for help
until they find a car
so they ask the driver to take them out
of there the lady agrees to take them
and on the way she says that there are
angels who take care of everyone
so nick gets a little scared and they
decide to get off at a store
nick asks haley to stay outside resting
and he goes into the store to use a
phone however he realizes
that it doesn't work
at that moment nick sees on the news
that he ran away and that he sees that
haley has just gotten on a trailer which
starts to move
nick leads quickly and with his new feet
manages to chase the trailer so he
reaches the door and makes the man stop
the vehicle then nick and haley take the
trailer and start driving down the road
while the suited men find the lady who
took nick and haley to the store and
interrogator to find out the location of
the teens
but they realize that the lady is
infected since she speaks strangely and
blood comes out of her nose
nick and haley reached the end of the
road and realize that they can't go to
the other side so they decide to go back
and find an abandoned house where they
can collect information
after searching the whole house they
don't find any valuable information and
without knowing where to go nick and
haley decide to spend the night in that
house
at night nick hears noises near the
house so that assigned to hide
but they realize that it's his friend
jonah who was dressed in a suit just
like the other man meanwhile the suited
man investigates a house where there is
a man who seems to be just as crazy as
the woman since he laughs out of nowhere
and suddenly screams then we see that
nick and jonah talk about what happened
to them and jonah tells him that all
that place is the same
they have not yet escaped from the
suited men since everything out there
also belongs to them
and they conclude that they're in area
51. nick tells his friend that they have
to get out of there fast since haley is
very sick so at that moment jonah shows
nick that they also experimented with
him and chosen his arms also affected by
alien technology
then nick promises him that they will
get out of there and jonah shows him a
map that shows the exit
the next day the three friends take the
trailer and head to the exit
but they realize that there are some men
who are checking the vehicles the
friends stop and jonah talks to the
guards since he has a suit similar to
the other men
while nick and hayley hide in the
backseat jonah tries to deceive them but
does not succeed and when they try to
leave by force the men catch the vehicle
and start shooting jonah gets out of the
car and runs the control room to free
the vehicle so that his friends can
escape
but once inside he cannot ride on the
computer due to his alien hands at that
moment the men throw a bomb at jonah and
he gets very hurt but he still manages
to hit the padlock that prevented the
trailer from moving and tells his
friends to leave without him
nick and haley decide to leave while
jonah stays to fight with the men then
nick and haley drive to the exit when
suddenly they see that the suited man
put cars in the road to prevent them
from passing
nick decides to accelerate and crash
into them
however they puncture his wheels so the
vehicle ends up overturned
the couple gets very hurt and nick
apologizes to haley for everything
that's happening
to which she only gives him a hug
at that moment the men in suits take
haley to a helicopter
nick gets up very injured
and watches haley leave in helicopter
the suited man tells nick that he won't
be able to reach hayley and nick
realizes the suited man is the hacker
they were looking for
nick gets very angry and suddenly his
feet start to glow getting a lot of
energy so he runs very fast towards the
exit
then when passing the exit it's as if he
had passed a barrier that takes him to a
very dark place
nick turns and sees that a hole was made
the barrier he just passed nick sees how
the hacker approaches and that he
actually has a body made of alien
technology and he only had the face of a
person
then nick turns back to see where he is
now standing and realizes that he's no
longer on earth but on a ship in space
the end
if you liked the video please leave a
like and subscribe to continue receiving
the recaps of the best sci-fi in action
movies
thanks for watching